if you thought House of the Dragon
couldn't get any crazier than honey
you've got a big storm coming in the
Game of Thrones Universe the second last
episode of a season has historically
been insane from the Battle of the
bastards to the Red Wedding judging from
this preview were in for one hell of a
ride a warning for those of you who are
new here this is a full book spoiler
video and for those of you who haven't
seen the trailer or my episode 8
breakdown I suggest you check those out
beforehand I've left links to them in
the description the Iron Throne sits
empty as Otto Hightower announces the
death of King viserys in the episode 8
subtitles we did see that the king's
breathing had stopped in the book The
King died at the age of 52 after 26
years on the throne so a pretty good run
compared to other kings now it does
appear to be night time here so I wonder
if we're picking up on the same night we
left on in episode 8. in the book
viserys died during the day while taking
a nap and Allison and the greens hid his
death for an entire a week before
announcing it to the public now I should
mention the name of this episode is the
green Council and here we see Allison
along with Otto and Sir Christian at the
head of the small Council the greens of
course refers to Allison's side in the
upcoming civil war known as the dance of
dragons rhaenyra's side is known as the
blacks but oddly enough that preview has
no footage of rhaenyra so I wonder if
this episode will focus purely on the
Queen's side this whole greens vs blacks
derived during the king and Allison's
fifth wedding anniversary where the
queen wore an extravagant green gown but
was as some would say outdone by
rhaenyra who dressed dramatically in
Targaryen red and black thus it became
custom in court to refer to either side
as green or black we have this member of
the kingsguard wiping off what could be
blood from a sword this is likely sir
Kristen however with the trailer's
emphasis on two other members of the
kingsguard twins Ark and Eric Cargill
it's possible it could be one of them we
do see someone with long hair perhaps
one of the cargills wearing black gloves
but considering members of The King's
Guard have identical uniforms and armor
we still can't be a hundred percent sure
maybe this blood is from Sir Harold
westerling will later get this shot of
Sir Kristen drawing his sword at the
Lord commander of the kingsguard
considering in the books sir Kristen
takes over Harold's spot as Lord
Commander well before viserys's death I
think it's a safe bet that Kristen kills
sir Harold after all I imagine Harold to
be loyal to rhaenyra and not the biggest
fan of Allison and her coup Kristen may
also be the one to kill master of coin
at Lyman beesbury he's been a stalwart
champion of King viserys's here we see
Allison in the dead of night this may be
shortly after the king's body is
discovered or perhaps she went straight
to Auto after she bathed the king good
night she'd obviously want to tell her
father the interpretation of what the
king said shortly before his death now
in the trailer she flat out says the
king said he wanted aegon to be king
this may be what she wanted to hear but
the king never said those words in his
milk of the poppy delirium he was
referring to aegon the Conqueror not
aegon his son I do think in Allison's
mind she believes this is what the king
wanted but that doesn't make it true she
also knows that the king had his doubts
about making rhaenyra Heir as he
expressed this to her in episode 3. here
we have a cloaked figure among the crowd
there are three cloaked figures we see
throughout the trailer one of them
belonging to Eamonn maybe it's him the
people of King's Landing are rushing
past the city garden toward a member of
the kingsguard here suggesting someone
Royal is nearby perhaps they're all
wanting a glimpse of the new king
there's also a world where the queen has
sealed off the city Gates as to keep the
King's death a secret but the ceiling of
the gates at this point in time does not
happen in the book here we have Otto
acting as the interim King until aegon's
coronation it seems as though he's
demanding the Lord's pledge their
allegiance to his grandson among the
members I can make out here are Lord
Caswell to the left and this might be
Otto's brother Hobart in the middle it
might also be Lyman beesberry but
considering he gets killed maybe not at
the meeting of the green Council Otto
says the door remains shut until they
finish their business so this has got to
be fresh after it's discovered the King
has died it's in this meeting that Lyman
beesberry finds himself killed and the
others make a pact to put aegon on the
throne instead of rhaenyra here's Eamon
giving the stink eye to his crown
brother aegon in the foreground notice
that the crown here is different than
that of viserys's in the book aegon
chose this Crown but even if he wanted
his father's Crown he couldn't have it
because it was stolen and smuggled out
of the city where it would be later
given to rhaenyra a bit later in this
preview I'll go over this Crown
significance we can also briefly see
Helena here to eamon's left and a member
of the kingsguard I think this is Sir
Kristen considering in the book he's the
one to Crown the king Auto tasks one of
the cargills with a secret mission in
which no one can know who he is or what
he seeks this could be a few things it
could be to retrieve aegon who in the
book was found in naked in the streets
after a night of debauchery it could be
to retrieve the stolen crown Ark is also
tasked with leading a contingent to
Dragonstone with an offer of peace to
rhaenyra should renera bend the knee to
aegon II she could keep Dragonstone and
pass it on to her son Jace upon her
death and Luke could keep a drift Mark
cargo's Mission could also be to
infiltrate Dragonstone posing as his
twin to kill or kidnap rhaenyra and or
her children although this event
shouldn't happen until later on in the
series to make matters more confusing
these twins end up siding with different
teams aric with aegon II and Eric with
rhaenyra this makes for some really
interesting drama as either of them
could pose as the other in order to spy
or do far worse here's rhaenis held
captive in the red keep she would be
considered an enemy of the high Towers
after siding with rhaenyra and Luke's
claim to drift mark this likely also
means that Bella is with her can
considering she is her ward in fact I
think this shot later in the trailer is
either Eric Cargill or sir Stefan
darklin leading a woman perhaps Bayla
out of the city you can see this person
carries with them a Black Satchel which
may carry viserys's crown portalia and
other servants are brought into the
dungeons of King's Landing this was done
by the high Towers in an attempt to rid
the city and castle of any who would be
sympathetic to renera but why then would
Talia be here she was a trusted
handmaiden of Allison I wonder if her
late night escapades acting as a spy to
masaria may have been discovered Allison
asks what of rhaenyra at the small
council meeting my interpretation is
that she's asking the others what to do
with her do they kill her make her a
peace offering whatever it is it seems
to be a very stressful decision for the
queen now this is one of the most
cryptic images from the trailer on the
one hand it looks like Dragon malt with
a cloaked figure jumping into a crevasse
if you look very closely you can make
out another object or person here
falling too considering the shot before
this is of that kingsguard leading a
cloaked figure through the city maybe
it's part of their escape jumping into
the water below to make their way to
Dragonstone and if it ain't that good
for nothing Lara strong who tells the
queen he's found something that she
should know the next shot is of a small
white-haired child if you saw my episode
8 breakdown you'd know that it was
rumored aegon fathered two bastards one
from a handmaiden likely Diana and the
other from a prostitute on the street of
silk if this is aegon's bastard child
what will Alison do here will she have
it killed like Cersei did Robert
baratheon's bastards now check out this
weird-ass fighting arena it looks as
though the common folk are having a hell
of a time watching kids duke it out if
you look closely on the back of this one
fighter you'll see the crest for house
Tully so maybe the common folk are
having these cage matches to see who
will win the dance of dragons here's
aemond out and about somewhere near
King's Landing take note of these Stone
spheres in the background as we'll later
see one of the car herbals fighting
someone around here Eamonn perhaps sir
Kristen draws his sword against Harold
westerling where we can see a few more
members of the green Council Jasper
Wilde master of laws Grand maester
Orwell and a dead master of coin Lyman
beesberry here's Allison looking even
more stressed sitting in the king's
chair she's listening to Lyman beesberry
saying that what's happening is seizure
and treason in the least those will
probably be some of his last words
members of the city watch create a path
for what might be the new king aegon
here are the cargills again and judging
by the background in rough and tumble
characters around them they are in that
fighting arena we saw earlier maybe
they're searching for Prince aegon as
will later see him running away from one
of them here we see some guards carrying
the Targaryen emblem during aegon's
Reign he will change the Targaryen
emblem from red to Gold some trumpet
players in what appears to be the dragon
pit will later see throngs of common
folk pack the pit which is likely to
announce and show their new king I
wonder if this also means aegon will be
on his drag Sunfire here is aegon chased
by one of the cargills in the same sept
where Alice and renera prayed in episode
2. I gotta admit it's a pretty good
hiding place because this would be the
least likely place you'd expect to find
aegon and aegon's tackled Otto overlooks
what might be the coronation of his
grandson looking rather proud this is
what he's been working towards for
decades and it's finally happening our
final shot is of this dark rusted Crown
this is significant because it's aegon
the conqueror's crown now being passed
onto aegon II in the book it is said to
be made of steel and adorned with rubies
but the rubies are missing here
voiceover of Renee states have you never
imagined yourself on the iron throne in
an earlier trailer we saw this line
delivered to Allison of course rhaenys
would have imagined herself on that
Throne considering it was essentially
stolen from her at the great Council
perhaps she's trying to justify some of
her actions to the queen I don't know
about you guys but this is my most
anticipated episode of the season if you
have haven't already please like And
subscribe and let me know in the
comments what you think will happen next
and if you want more content check out
my episode 8 breakdown thanks for
watching for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
you can keep his tongue